uh okay this next question here is it's
funny because this this is one i wanted
to ask you kind of like not necessarily
for me actually it's not for me at all
thankfully but um
so this is interesting because i know
all right hey hi jacko an echo i just
started to go to a new gym a couple
months ago i was focused on getting in
shape and sorting out my life i've made
good progress in the last few weeks i'm
not uh from here so i don't know a lot
of people in the small town usa quote
unquote
i have one workout partner and we work
out almost every day together anyway
since starting to work out i've begun to
date a girl who works out there too
she approached me and everything is
going great and i really like her she's
quite pretty and social and fit so she
gets looks attention from other guys
looks at attention from other guys
however i'm having a serious i'm having
serious trouble
with the jealous ex boyfriend of hers
who is bad-mouthing me to everyone at
the gym and and to her spreading lies
and attempting to ruin my reputation you
know he also bad mouse my workout
partner
neither this isn't part of the question
i wanted to ask him just this is a
build-up neither of us neither of us
know this guy he takes photos of my car
in parking lots with females and
randomly walking by and sending them to
her and attempting to frame me for
having other girls in my car
he's always telling her he's not so he's
got so much [ __ ] on me and is attempting
to do anything he can to derail what
we've got going on he owes her quite a
bit of money and she says this is the
only reason she hasn't stopped all
contact with him he's always calling her
going to her job and following us around
if we go for walks at the park etc how
do i deal with this is the question how
do i deal with a person who is
attempting to ruin what i have going on
so how does your question oh well mine
was like actually this is way more
elaborate than whatever mine was just
like how do you deal with like um like
jealous ex-boyfriends kind of a thing
you know like because there's kind of
two sides to it where you can take
totally take the high road but like to
what degree you know like so what do you
think i'm gonna do
well you know give me a minute kelly i
don't know tell him to wake up at 4 30
in the morning well
in this city well you just said you know
you tell him to take of course i'm gonna
tell you to take the high road
and listen in a situation like that you
don't have to do much to a guy like this
a guy like this is ruining everything
for himself
people see through this kind of trash
talking this kind of trash attitude
people see jealousy people see envy
people see crazy obsessions they see
that's so obvious bro
it's obvious
and everybody's gonna see that
so don't get dragged down into it
it's matter of fact when you
drag yourself down you're you're you're
gonna be in the same
[ __ ] that he's in look like an idiot
look like you're dude
like what are you he's jealous of course
he jealous of me you know i got a
girlfriend he doesn't have a girlfriend
like hey man sorry it didn't work out
for you good luck you know like to be
like you better back off it's like bro
you're making yourself look like an
idiot don't do it
um so so yes maintain the high high
ground
you don't need to be negative
about this guy you can just kind of
shrug your shoulders you know when
someone says hey fred said that you were
you know you you freaking can't even
bench you know 300. and you can be like
hey man
yeah i guess i need to work hey fred's
right i need to work on my bench you
know like that's it you know
well you don't say well you know fred
bubble no he's going yeah
definitely need to work on my bench cool
right
think of how if you came to me and you
said hey jacqueline's talking to dean
dean said you can't even bench 300.
and i went well you know what dean do
you know what i mean yeah and i said
well you know what dean
i'd like to see dean do do run a four
miles in 28 minutes that guy's totally
out of shape i don't care what his bench
is
instead if i go if if and if versus if i
said yeah man definitely need to work on
my bench
like who's the more secure alpha for
lack of a better word because we did
that
who's the who's the who's the more
confident human
it's the one that's like oh yeah
definitely need to work on my bench no
factor
appreciate the feedback all good
so
don't be negative don't worry about it
it's no big deal and and this should
should keyword fade
now
there's
something that you do need to be aware
of this doesn't mean you need to freak
out about it but you need to be aware of
it is this dude actually a crazy person
right
is there a legitimate threat
is does this escalate like he's taking
pictures of your car like that's weird
so there's some indicators
that
he might not that he might have issues
most people like you blow them off for a
little while you you say hey yeah man i
definitely need to work on my bench
yeah hey you know jessica i yeah i know
she can be a little wild but you know
we're getting along right now you know
if you just try and be nice and polite
to people eventually they realize
they're not going to get anything out of
you and they're going to move on to
their next crazy obsession
uh
but
he might not right that's why i would
definitely look at documenting some of
what he's doing right he's taking
pictures he's making some kind of threat
save those things
uh make sure that he's not an actual
threat
and if he starts to
habitually cross the line you might have
to talk to him
and don't be emotional you know be
talk to him from the high ground hey
listen bud hey man i know that you and
jessica were together
and i get that
um i i know that you're broke up and
i've been going out with her for a while
and
look
it's nothing it's no offense to you
but you can you back off a little bit
because it seems weird
it seems weird and i'm just trying to
you know carry on with my life and
if you could back off that'd be cool and
see if he you know if you put some
boundaries up because what are you
talking about man i'm talking about the
fact that you're texting her pictures of
people by girls by my car and accusing
me of hooking up with other girls which
is crazy
so
just do me a favor just like
just back off and i understand there's
some money you might owe her and let's
get that taken care of so we can move on
but
so see where that goes now if that
doesn't work you might have to escalate
a little bit more which is
explaining that hey man if you don't
back off like i'm gonna actually talk to
the authorities about what you're doing
this is harassment
and
here's the
most likely it's not going to come to
that
and i'm not one of these uh
what is it like hey you push me i'm
calling the cops like that you know like
that thing right which is oh that that's
kind of a weak way to go around your
life like hey
you know oh you bumped into me now we're
gonna get in a fight and i'm like i'll
call the cops right this is not that
this is not an emotional this is a very
unemotional hey man
like you've you've talked to him twice
you've said hey here's the boundaries
and he's violating these boundaries and
you go hey listen man if you don't like
stop doing this kind of stuff i'm
actually going to talk to the
authorities because this is starting to
be considered harassment and i'm not
going to let jessica be harassed by you
and look i don't care really care what
you do to me it bothers me but i'm not
gonna let you harass my girlfriend
so if you don't back off i'm actually
gonna talk to law enforcement and take
some legal ramifications
and here's
what's it shouldn't come to that
but if it does then guess what legal
action was actually required
you see what i'm saying it's a test
that the answer to the test is the
solution
so
think about that hey one more thing to
think about i gotta throw this in there
no offense
well who is this girl like what is she
crazy does she have weird baggage are
you the pawn that's getting played
getting manipulated making this guy
jealous she likes that kind of drama in
her life just i'm just throwing it out
there
he owes me mike who loves people money
right
and you want to you you remember like
you'd go out to a bar and there would be
like the girl that would start you know
get to get her boyfriend in fights all
the time
you know what i'm talking about you are
a bouncer you you know what i'm talking
about right yeah
didn't happen that often but that's real
it's a real thing yeah like what are you
looking at
you know bobby he's looking at me you're
like bobby's like oh god here we go
again
right
is just check yourself check jessica
whatever her name is make sure that
she's not a drama person and some of
this isn't stemming from her like it is
weird she's still communicating with
this dude okay how much money be like
hey dude he owes you 400 bucks here's
400 bucks delete his delete his number i
got it yeah you know
i'll pay his debt
so that you can just walk away from this
idiot
and if she's like no i want it from him
then you're like oh i'm suspect you see
what i'm saying yes so just check that
and pay it you use this term earlier i'm
gonna use again pay attention
don't be paranoid but don't be naive
that's what i'm saying high road don't
be paranoid don't be naive
yeah there's um
that's interesting that was uh
i'm not surprised by anything you said
but the high road seems um you know the
always the right play it's always the
right place from a strategic perspective
and it's a good reminder where
like everyone sees what's going on
everyone sees what's going on like this
that is probably one of the most
profound things you can recognize yeah
is that everyone wait i mean everyone
sees
or is going to see what's going on yeah
and if you if that person's acting like
an idiot look out of the gate some
people might be like oh yeah fred's
right you know freaking echo showed up
here now he's dating jessica that's kind
of messed up
but then people are like oh they broke
up yeah before echo even showed up here
and by the way that guy's in here like
throwing weights around you know i mean
this guy's a dork yeah
and so people see
the truth the truth settles out it
doesn't always settle out immediately
and it doesn't always settle out
perfectly but it settles out in a way
that the truth is known and if you have
confidence in that it gives you such
power in life
because it allows you to it allows you
to take your ego
and
gratify your ego by saying hey listen to
ego it's going to be okay in the long
term because your ego wants
gratification what are you talking about
she's mine no one's like no hey man
listen i know you went out with her it's
all good
you guys aren't going out anymore so i
started going out with her
and that's the way that's what's
happening right now
hey
i i i'm sure look i can see by the look
on your face it doesn't bother you i'm
not trying to rub it in your face but
you all broke up
and so let's just make some space
you know i'm not i'm not coming i'm not
going over the squat rack when you're in
there you stay away from the squat rack
when i'm in there how's that for a deal
let's move on man yeah and if you can be
cool and you can take the high ground
other people will eventually realize it
and you feel like well everyone's gonna
think i'm a wimp no they're gonna think
you're actually just smart
yeah and and you could probably figure
that by just taking your detaching as
you say but take yourself out of that
situation and put someone else in there
where like let's say you you'd be my
friend like literally let's say it was
you we were young you had a girlfriend
or whatever
um wait are you gonna get your ass beat
right now no hypothetically i do i do
run that risk yesterday
but um if you're
you know you and your girlfriend break
up right let's say the girlfriend's like
just normal girlfriend she wasn't a
psycho she was nothing like that just
you and a good girl normal dateable girl
whatever you guys break up for whatever
reason and months later
we go to the gym she's talking to this
new guy and now she's dating him and
then you start bad-mouthing her and the
new guy to me like all the time like all
the time
and the new guy
in this scenario takes the high ground
he's just like oh yeah saying the stuff
that you said he's acting like that
probably even me
bias me yeah again against these guys
your friend i see what's going on we're
like bro
you're looking like an idiot or i might
sign on to your thing like hell yeah let
me jump in the low ground with you but
now everyone no everyone sees you and
your dumb friend doing dumb stuff like
everyone sees that stuff everyone sees
man but i will say this
i think it might be the girl
oh so you're glad i threw that caveat
yes i'm glad because i feel like that's
that's the case a lot of the time with
this drum when there's drama going on
a lot of times it's a girl man and not
to say she means it because she's drama
but she allows a lot of the drama for
whatever reason i can't read no girl's
mind but like you know how
he was a red flag
i you you say you think it's the girl i
i think that's strong yeah i think i
think it's a necessary caveat that there
is a chance that it could be the girl i
think you're going too strong yeah and
you make a good point and and i i
apologize you're saying it could be the
girl which i agree that is in play big
time in this whole thing because you're
trying to strengthen it it's a play it's
implied it's playing okay so and this is
why it's not big time because it is in
play it's a possibility hey look i'm no
relationship
sociologist okay nothing like this okay
but
this was the red flag
all right what's the red flag
um
she uh he owes her money that's why she
hasn't broken all contact with him so
there has to be some justifiable reason
why she's still talking to this guy
right and she owes him money it's
understandable right it's kind of bri it
kind of feels like a thing like an
excuse almost like
you know how like the girl just kind of
i don't know i could again i can't read
her i don't know the girl but you know
sometimes the girl like she does she
doesn't mind it you know the guy like
obsessing over her it's an indicator man
yeah yeah it's an indicator watch out
she's got a little thread she's pulling
that string yeah what's that dragging
along what's that term
true trailing no um stringing them along
straight
little string out there maybe could be
so that's why we say advised be advised
it could be a scenario yeah yeah okay i
agree with you you're right
all right last question